alors que la france vient de dépasser
les 10 millions d'injections la bataille
contre le coc u19 se conjugue aussi au
futur
le laboratoire cdm lavoisier à la
chaussée-saint-victor va multiplier par
deux sa production de solvants pour
vaccins et pour l'aider l'état va
débourser un million et demi d'euros
d'ici 2023 annonce tout à l'heure de la
ministre de l'industrie en visite sur le
site sur place on retrouve samuel colin
sécuriser la production européenne de
solution injectable lusine cdm lavoisier
produit 35 médicaments différents
l'objectif affiché de cet agrandissement
quasiment doubler la production et le
stockage du site
on a un objectif d'accroître notre notre
capacité de production notamment sur des
ampoules plastique en installant une
nouvelle ligne de fabrication de ces en
plastique
on est obligés d'adapter notre outil de
l'industriel donc en créant de nouvelles
infrastructures pour stocker les volumes
qui vont être produits mais aussi en
amont créer des nouveaux systèmes de
production d'eau purifiée de groupes
froids ou une nouvelle chaufferie tel
convoi derrière moi et dans le cadre de
son plan de relance l'état s'engage ici
à hauteur d'un million et demi d'euros
sur les 7 du projet lusine fabrique par
exemple du chlorure de sodium utilisé
notamment dans les hôpitaux mais aussi
pour la fabrication de vaccins des
solutions injectables qui ne sont pas
fabriqués en quantité suffisante
ici en europe selon la ministre chargé
de l'industrie
aujourd'hui les capacités de production
on le voit son doivent être développées
la rn message is est une technologie
nouvelle est typiquement la france n'a
aucun site
aucun site aujourd'hui à date capable de
produire de la substance active en
quantité industrielle
et c'est cela que nous devons réparer et
que nous devons à des gouvernements qui
n'ont pas investi en matière de santé il
se rattrape âge est essentielle la
nouvelle ligne de production qui
s'ajoute donc aux quatre déjà existantes
devraient sortir de terre à l'horizon